Michelle Obito has worked in comedy for
more than 20 years she's cracking us up
just in the freaking commercial funny
successful winning a Critics Choice
Award thank you very much for a special
welcome to Utopia now she's a co-creator
did you hear that part and star hear
that part of a new series survival of
the thickest it's inspired by her
acclaimed book of essays published by an
imprint of Simon and Schuster which like
CBS is part of Paramount Global you know
that part buto Place Maeve is a
struggling stylist who is who has to
start all over again after leaving her
cheating EX
don't look crazy I feel crazy yes you
look crazy I'm moving you to Brooklyn to
live with a total stranger yes who could
be a serial killer or Worse an
investment banker really those are my
only two options come on Khalil
roomyfinder.net is a legitimate website
okay I paid three whole dollars to sign
up for that website and I saw on the
back of a bus so I know it's real and on
FaceTime Jade like at least four and a
half minutes and she had kind eyes and
um didn't ask for my credit score which
is like the most important
gotta go you gotta go we gotta go why
Lisa top head oh Leo are you serious
when are you gonna stop running from
women you slept with we are 38 years old
obviously
[Laughter]
executive producer of survival of the
thickest good morning we are so glad
you're here welcome 10 minutes ago you
were sitting in the chair with a t-shirt
yes and bare feet and now you come out
explain the look and how you're feeling
in the look today oh my goodness I am
giving uh Diana Ross nine to five bank
manager realness you know what I mean
I'm going to ask you what you do for a
living and give you a red lollipop so
yeah I I love bringing a little pm to
the am if that makes sense no I'm
excited this doesn't button there's no
buttons it doesn't have to you just have
to feel your most beautiful self however
that is for you okay okay no she was
when she said I have on this this I have
on her new bra so I feel really good oh
new bra will do that for you it does it
makes you walk different it's like new
sneakers for you guys I don't know oh
that makes sense Tony yeah how to break
in New Sneakers you got to break in a
new bra you got it and you gotta break
in new ties like I don't know why
clearance is going on but I'm here for
it
I love the title survival of the
thickest does it have a double meaning
for you survival of the thickest 100 it
is thick it's plus size it's beautiful
it's fatty baddies Audi bodies loving
yourself no matter what you know and
it's also going through stuff you need
thick skin you have to learn and grow
and evolve from your experiences don't
let it break or shake you just learn
from it like I have been doing stand-up
comedy for a long time I'm very funny if
you can't tell and I always learn from
the bad shows more than the good shows
really and I think people want to feel
safe and their ego wants to be stroked
all the time but you got to get messy
you got to be comfortable with rejection
and figure out who you are in that
moment and so that's what this show is I
like that and I like uh that you take a
label that can can be looked at as a
negative connotation and you flip it to
a positive so you know when it comes to
thick is it okay for guys to call a
woman thick like if a guy says you know
she's Thicker Than a Snicker
oh see she's thicker than a pot of cold
oatmeal
first grade picture
I'm saying like is that okay
okay
back in the day yeah okay my
body because you know this is how I I
teach my kids too it's not what you say
it's how you say it yeah so if you're
saying it like that with love and
prepping your step But A nice bright red
tie with matching socks okay yes honey
you can say Thicker Than a Snicker
that's okay with me yes uh it is how you
say it and on the subject of how you say
it I was reading that you had a college
professor when you went to this
professor and you said you want to be an
entertainment reporter yes he said I'm
presuming it's a he maybe it was a she
that's a bad plan for you because of
your build oh my God oh my goodness look
at you you do my research you really
have I'm not sure that happened it is so
I went to school for TV production and I
really wanted to be a journalist and um
my professor told me that I was just
simply too fat to be on camera and yeah
she used the word fat he said he did
that yes wow um you know this was a long
time ago and our vocabulary has changed
thank God but how did you take that in
that moment yeah yeah you know I was um
embarrassed I wasn't even mad I was just
more embarrassed
um I didn't I was taught to respect my
elders so I didn't even know how to
question him this was in front of the
class and I just thought you know what
he's not wrong I don't see anyone like
me on camera so I started working in TV
production I used to edit for the local
news wnbc how you doing hope you got
that cooked coffee today and
um yeah I just there was this little
thing inside of me I was like I can't
just keep editing for people you're
right you didn't see anyone like you so
this is one of those cases where you
have to wait for the world to catch up
with you yeah you're not catching up
with the world yes and that has been my
Mantra since day one you know it has
been a journey especially for anyone who
will go into the store and not find
their size because then you just feel
like you're not seen by anybody right
and so you know it is ridiculous to
think that you will ever be attractive
by an unrealistic patriarchal standard
so you don't need to be bikini body
ready you already have a body you ready
yeah and so yeah I will say that it is
not you that needs to catch up to the
world it's the world that needs to catch
up to you okay Michelle the other thing
I like about what you do in survival of
the thickest she has a cheater cheater
boyfriend that she catches yeah and then
as the story evolves is she going to go
back with him not go back with him but
you introduce the love interest who is
very good looking an Italian guy yeah
that's not normally how that goes in
these particular stories why was that
important to you because Luca number one
love the name yes and the fact that he
was so dreamy and the two of them really
connected yeah so Lucas played by
marwanzadi shout out to him because
um you know he's this amazing actor in
Italy yeah
um you know that was I may destroy you
and um it was important for me to
Showcase that Mavis could be desired
wanted love have options have options
have options yes I think a lot of people
especially mavis's parents and I know
people in the real world who will tell
you this is the guy you should be with
you've already put five into six years
you know you've made your plan he's good
on paper he comes from good stock
whatever people outside influence
influences are telling you but it's like
what happens when you make a choice for
yourself and you have chemistry and
connection yeah you know even if it
doesn't work out at least you saw the
follow through and so it was important
for me to Showcase that Mavis could be
desired because big women are beautiful
right that's right damn right you didn't
agree I'm just kidding
foreign
you said I have no idea what I'm doing I
just know I'm the best at doing it yeah
um that's powerful because that can
apply to anything yes but but why did
you say that specifically about
motherhood I think it's just so
important for your mental health to
kind of
commit and and and explore and talk
about what you don't know right you
don't have to put this unnecessary
pressure on yourself to always have it
right how can you ever describe
something or get it right if you've
never done it before yeah you know and
so I really like to follow my instinct
and so you know four and a half year old
twins it is challenging yeah
um but you know it took me so long to
have these children I'm so glad I got to
meet these beautiful souls because we
did struggle with ibf for five years and
we ended up going down the road of
surrogacy and it was illegal in New York
at that time and I stopped by Andy Cohen
Albany and then it you know it yeah it
is legal now which is amazing that
people can have alternative family
planning but alternative is just a word
for like love right and so you know um
but look at your life though Michelle
beautiful children great partner and a
knockout series yes I just want to end
with some of the great lines
while this fantasy has become your
truest realities like that dreaming big
makes life worth living and sometimes we
have to make the wrong decision before
we make the right one and it all applies
in Mavis beaumont's life Michelle Vito
we adore you
sorry survival of the thickest premieres
this Thursday on Netflix